LOGAN URY: So my
name is Logan Uri.
I'm here visiting Seattle
from the Mountain View
office, where I work as
a behavioral researcher.
And I am so glad
that we can welcome
Doctor John Gottman and
Doctor Julie Schwartz Gottman
here today.
So, thank you so much
for joining us at Google.
We're thrilled to have you.
I've been a fan of
yours for many years,
I'm so glad that you're here.
And this is our fourth event in
our series on modern romance.
So, first I'll
introduce the Gottmans
and then I'll ask
them some questions,
and then we'll invite you all
up at the end to ask questions
at this podium at the mic.
So, first we have
Doctor John Gottman.
He is world renowned for his
work on marital stability
and divorce prediction.
He's conducted forty years
of breakthrough research
with thousands of couples.
He was recognized as one of
the top 10 most influential
therapists of the
past quarter century
by the Psychotherapy Networker.
He's also the author of 190
published academic articles,
and the author or co-author
of 40 books including
a bestselling "The Seven
Principles for Making Marriage
Work," "What Makes Love Last,"
and "The Relationship Cure."
He's also the co-founder
of the Gottman Institute
with his wife, and
he's professor emeritus
of psychology at the
University of Washington,
where he founded the love
lab to research couples.
Now, Doctor Julie
Schwartz Gotttman
is the co-founder and president
of the Gotttman Institute.
She's also highly recognized
as a clinical psychologist, who
has worked with distressed
couples, abuse and trauma
survivors, substance
abusers and their partners,
and cancer patients
and their families.
She's also the co-author of
the immensely popular "The Art
and Science of Love" weekend
workshops for couples,
and the author of
four books including
"Ten Lesson to
Transform your Marriage"
and "Baby Makes Three."
Wow, those are
quite introductions.
[LAUGHTER]
JULIE GOTTMAN: Yeah
LOGAN URY: So, thank you
so much for joining us,
and [APPLAUSE] So,
for those people
in the audience who aren't
as familiar with your work,
I want to start
at the beginning.
Who are the four horsemen,
and why is their presence
so dangerous for couples?
JOHN GOTTMAN: No, you take it.
JULIE GOTTMAN: No, you.
[LAUGHTER] OK.
All right.
So--
JOHN GOTTMAN: She
got the microphone.
JULIE GOTTMAN: Is this on?
LOGAN URY: Yes.
JULIE GOTTMAN: All right.
So the four horsemen--
how many of you
have heard of the four
horsemen of the apocalypse?
Yeah?
Heard of it?
OK.
So these are the big
predictors of demise
in relationships,
for really destroying
the path of relationships.
The first one is criticism.
Which is, talking
down to your partner,
blaming your partner for a
problem in a relationship.
Blaming the problem on a
personality flaw, basically.
Telling your partner they're
lazy, they're a slob,
they're a jerk.
All of those lovely words
that we hat to hear, right?
The second one is contempt.
And contempt is even worse.
Contempt is criticism
but from a place
on high, superior position.
So, it's sort of like
this, do you remember
when you were a teenager?
Do you remember when your
parents said terrible things
to you?
And you would go [SIGH].
Remember that expression?
That's an expression
of contempt.
So if you see that in your
partner, that's trouble.
Sarcasm, abuse.
Kind of abusive put-downs.
You're such a bitch.
That kind of stuff, not said
lightly, really is contempt
and what we've learned
about contempt,
was that it was the
worst predictor,
the most powerful predictor
of relationship demise.
And not only did it predict
relationships going down,
the number of
contempt expressions
that a listener
heard in 15 minutes
predicted how many infectious
illnesses the listener
would have in the next month.
Isn't that incredible?
So, it's frightening.
So, contempt actually erodes
the immune system as well as
the heart, the relationship.
The third horseman
is defensiveness.
And defensiveness
is usually either,
I did too pay the
bills, you know,
kind of that righteous
victim thing?
Or counter-attack.
Oh yeah, well, you didn't
pick up the dry cleaning.
The counter-attack.
Defensiveness is the
hardest one to eliminate.
How many of us have
been defensive?
Like all of us, right?
So John and I are
continually still working
that, after 30 years.
It's tough.
So defensiveness is a
response to feeling attacked,
that's why we get defensive.
The fourth one we
call stonewalling.
And this was my darling's
brilliant research
break-through, one
of them, one of many,
which related stonewalling,
which means completely shutting
down in the middle
of a conversation,
and not giving any response
at all, no head nods,
looking away,
usually, looking down,
and, you know, hoping the
ogre sitting across from you
will go away.
That's stonewalling.
And why John discovered,
was that typically,
when people were stonewalling,
their heart-rates
were above 100 beats a
minute, just sitting there.
Sometimes it would be as
high as 140 beats per minute,
really high.
Meaning, they were
in fight or flight,
that [INAUDIBLE]
physiological arousal,
and that was leading
them to stonewall.
That's our fourth, and
it's a problem [INAUDIBLE].
There you go.
Now you can go out and
destroy your relationships.
[LAUGHTER]
LOGAN URY: That's a
great introduction.
So, John, I read
a story about you
that I really
liked, when you met
the young, unimpressed publisher
of "The Seven Principles
for Making Marriage
Work," and he said,
tell me one thing in
the next 30 seconds
that I can do to improve
my marriage right now.
Can you please share
that story, as well as
your favorite advice
for couples who want
to improve their relationships.
JOHN GOTTMAN: Yeah,
it was a great moment,
because I was trying to convince
Random House to invest money
in marketing the
book, and he was
unimpressed with the
videotapes I presented.
So he said, tell
me one thing I can
do to improve my marriage
in the next 30 seconds.
I said, well there's a
lot of things of the book,
but if I had to pick
one, I would say
it's honor your wife's dreams.
And this guy sat
up, put on his coat,
and walked out of the
meeting. [LAUGHTER] I thought,
I blew that one.
He's the head of marketing.
So, I found out later that
he actually went home, took
the subway to Brooklyn,
and he walked in
and his wife was there.
She said, did you get fired?
He said, no, no.
I came home to find out
what your dreams are.
Because he didn't have a clue.
So they had a great conversation
that afternoon and he
decided to put money in
marketing the book after that.
[LAUGHTER].
LOGAN URY: That's so beautiful.
And what's your advice for
people in the audience for what
they can do?
Maybe not in thirty seconds,
to improve their relationship?
JOHN GOTTMAN: You
know, I really think
Julie hit the nail on the head.
Because when I thought
about it, the work that's
required in relationships, and
we can prove mathematically
that relationships are
systems that require energy,
they're dissipative
energy systems.
And if anybody's
interested in the math,
you could look it up in
the book that I recently
published on it.
But based on the math model,
now, you have to do work,
or the relationship
deteriorates over time.
And I think the work
really is down-regulating
your own defensiveness.
Which means that when your
partner is angry with you,
or disappointed in you, you've
hurt your partner's feelings.
Instead of reacting really
quickly, and saying, bullshit,
I didn't do that.
Or, it's your problem.
You really way to beat, and
then when you speak you say,
OK I'm listening, talk to me.
And I think that's the work.
It's really hard work.
And we still work at it.
So it doesn't ever
get, really, easier.
No one ever feels joyful about
their partner's disappointment
or anger with them or having you
hurt your partner's feelings.
It's just something that
happens all the time.
But, people come to our
couples' weekend workshop,
and they're always
thinking, this is great,
you know, I'm glad I'm here,
because she really needs this.
[LAUGHTER] You know, I'm
fine, but she really needs
a lot of communication work.
But they're always surprised and
horrified that the work really
is work you have
to do on yourself.
LOGAN URY: So, you talked
being a better listener,
but I also read your
criticism around
how some people think
active listening is
the cure all for marriages.
What are some other
misconceptions around what
can help save a marriage?
JOHN GOTTMAN: Part of the
reason that active listening is
a mistake, the idea that
every time Julie says
something, if I'm listening
I paraphrase what she says
and summarize it, is that nobody
can listen to a person who's
attacking them.
You know, there has
to be responsibility
not just on the listener,
but on the speaker as well.
So we talk a lot about
softened start-up, about how
the masters of the
relationship really
think before they
present an issue,
and they try to really calm
their partner down and say,
hey, this isn't
a big deal, baby,
but, here's what I really need.
Rather than the
horseman, they're
pointing their
fingers at themselves,
and saying this is what
I'm feeling and here's
a recipe for be successful
with me, instead of pointing
the finger at their partner and
saying, you are so, you know,
and all that.
JULIE GOTTMAN: Yeah,
let me add to that.
One of the big
misconceptions about how
to be in a good relationship is,
first of all don't get angry,
anger is a bad thing.
And the reality is that anger
is not a bad thing, it just is.
It's organic, it's part
of our brains hard wiring.
It's and organic think
that needs to be expressed,
but how it's
expressed is they key.
So, as were talking
earlier, it can
be expressed through criticism
and through contempt, or more
a description of, I'm
frustrated, I'm furious,
then about what, not about who.
So, I'm upset that the
kitchen is still a mess.
The kitchen a is still
a mess is the situation
you're angry about, it's not a
personality flaw of a partner.
And then, saying what you mean.
It's so important to
say what you mean.
And what you do need,
rather than what you don't.
I need you stop being a jerk.
Is your partner going
to want to hear that?
I don't think so.
So, you know, I need you to
be kind to me when I'm being
interviewed in front of a
million people. [LAUGHTER] So,
there's-- hear that?
[LAUGHTER] So
expressing your needs
is also a really
important thing to do.
LOGAN URY: So what about sex?
How important is sex
to your relationship.
JOHN GOTTMAN: Oh, boy.
JULIE GOTTMAN: Our
favorite topic.
[LAUGHTER]
LOGAN URY: Isn't that
the name of your website?
Got sex?
JULIE GOTTMAN: I'm not going
to-- [LAUGHTER] We didn't think
of that, I mean, it took a
25 year old to think of that.
[LAUGHTER] So, should
we talk about sex?
JOHN GOTTMAN: OK
JULIE GOTTMAN: So, sex is in
important in a relationship,
it's a way of expressing
fondness, admiration,
love, cherishing the person,
but an important thing is
that it needs to be personal.
Needs to be personal, sex.
So what we're
talking about there,
is blending emotional intimacy
with physical intimacy.
So, lots of people
are doing hook-ups,
everyone's doing
hook-ups these days.
That's impersonal sex.
You don't know who
your having sex with.
So, what are you actually doing?
Well, you're kind of
doing mutual masturbation,
you're stimulating each other.
So, that's not what
preserves a relationship.
What preserves a
relationship is really
understanding what
turns your partner on,
understanding how
your partner wants sex
to be initiated, in a way
that's comforting to them,
and how a person can refuse
sex without destroying
the ego of the
other person, right?
So having those
discussions about sex,
openly and honestly,
is one of the things
that can really help strengthen
the physical relationship.
JOHN GOTTMAN: I
need to take notes,
because my wife is
talking about sex.
[LAUGHTER] So, you know there
are a lot of misconceptions
about this, and one of the
most common misconceptions
is that too much intimacy
destroys eroticism.
Well, familiarity
breeds contempt.
LOGAN URY: I just read
"Mating in Captivity."
JOHN GOTTMAN: "Mating in
Captivity," good example.
Esther Perel says, don't wear
that flannel nightgown ladies,
because it'll turn
your partner off.
Wear that sexy negligee
and be mysterious.
Now, don't really share all of
your secrets with your partner,
have some mystery.
And do not cuddle, cuddling is
the death knell for eroticism.
And she advises her
clients not to cuddle,
and in fact she has
advised her clients
to ask for money for sex.
[LAUGHTER] Making sex
impersonal is her recipe
for increased eroticism.
Well, we actually have
good data on this now.
From 70,000 people who reported
about their intimate sexual
relationships online, from
24 different countries,
and in fact everywhere on the
planet, the opposite is true.
Couples who kiss one another
good bye when they go to work,
turns out that there's
a study in Germany,
if men kissed their wives
goodbye versus men who don't?
Those men who do kiss
their wives goodbye
live five years longer.
So what are they tapping into?
In all of these
countries, sex is the same
and romance is the same.
So people who have
great sex lives, kissed
one another passionately for no
reason at all, hug each other.
They cuddle, they give surprise
gifts, compliments, flowers,
and they do the kinds of
things that really Ester Perel
is saying not to do.
And furthermore,
most of us really
know how to get underneath that
flannel nightgown very easily.
[LAUGHTER]
JULIE GOTTMAN: I don't wear one.
LOGAN URY: So
you've done research
into relationships and
marriage for the last 40 years.
And obviously there's been
big changes in this phase,
such as many more
women in the workplace,
and many more people meeting
through online dating.
So, through the years of
your research, what's changed
and what's stayed the same.
JULIE GOTTMAN: That's
an interesting question.
I think part of
what's changed, is
that the percentage of women
that are having affairs
has gone up.
Because in the '50s and early
'60s when data was collected,
this sort of data was collected
back then, women didn't work.
Women were at home drinking
coffee with their neighbors,
and the neighbors were all
other women staying home
with the kids like they were.
So they didn't
really have access
to other partners
outside their spouse.
Now, with women having
entered the workforce,
there's lots of access,
and so their percentage
of-- the ones that are
having affairs are going up.
But at the same
time, you know what's
interesting is that people
still want the same thing
for the most part.
Most people still want a
committed relationship.
They still want
things, they still
want something
that's long-lasting.
They want their partner
to be a close friend.
They want, you know maybe
this is a little different,
they want equality in terms
of the roles that each plays,
in terms of all
the daily activity,
taking care of the
house, the kids, etc.
So there is more
equality, especially
in the younger
generation, who've
been raised with those values.
And there's balance I think
to some degree, between men
and women and whose
career path you follow.
There's more
flexibility in that.
So men are following women's
career paths sometimes too, as
opposed to the other way around.
What do you think, dear?
JOHN GOTTMAN: Well I would say
that the biggest thing that's
happened at least in
the last 60 years,
is the erosion of
trust in our culture.
And Robert Putnam in
the book "Bowling Alone"
talked about this
on a societal level.
And you see since 1960 in
the United States of America,
a big decline community.
People are more
alone and lonely,
they don't join
organizations, and probably
the best indicator of
this is the disparity
between what the poorest
people in a culture
and what the richest
people in a culture earn.
And this has been
growing enormously.
So that earlier in the
United States, in the '50s,
a CEO of major
corporations would
earn 25 times what the
average worker earned,
and now CEOs are
earning 350 times what
the average worker is earning.
And if you look,
even internationally,
this erosion of
trust is reflected
at all levels of society.
So these indicators
of how much do people
trust other people, just
as a very simple question
that sociologist
ask on the phone,
is related to the
overall health of people,
longevity, school achievement
of children, crime.
And the statistics are
really quite dramatic,
both within the United States
of America and internationally.
But on an interpersonal
level, we've
also seen an erosion of trust.
So that now, the major
thing that people
want when they select a
partner, is trustworthiness.
That's the quality
they're looking for.
And I think Julie's right.
We want to be with
somebody who's
really going to be
with us for a lifetime
and going to cherish us.
And will take care of
us when we're sick,
be with us for
richer or for poorer,
just like the wedding
vows, but now it's
even more important
to find somebody
who will really stay the
course with us and we rely on.
JULIE GOTTMAN: May I add
just one more thing Logan?
LOGAN URY: Yes, please.
JULIE GOTTMAN: I think one of
the biggest negative impacts
of the past ten years or
so is internet pornography.
So we are seeing, within
the clinical [INAUDIBLE],
we are seeing huge impact
of internet pornography
on couples.
On course, there was
always "Playboy" magazine
or something, but it's never
been as accessible, as secret,
as easy to hide.
And so millions, and
millions, and millions,
and millions of people are
going on internet porn.
And the effect of that,
when people really
use it frequently, is that
it changes their expectations
of sex with their partner.
They want the sex
with their partner
to look like what they're
watching on the computer.
And of course, it's impersonal
sex that they're watching.
And I've seen some of
the carryover of that
into relationships, that
really can be very disastrous.
LOGAN URY: Well, that
was fascinating and not
what I was expecting, so
I really appreciate it.
And I would love to
talk more about trust,
and how people can
build trust, and then
after a betrayal,
which I think you say
is one of the biggest issues
in the end of a marriage.
How can people repair
trust, without necessarily
breaking up?
JULIE GOTTMAN: What
do you want to know?
[LAUGHTER]
LOGAN URY: Yeah, what are the
foundations of building trust,
and how do you repair it?
JOHN GOTTMAN: OK, so
here's one of the places
where mathematics
really illuminates
the nature of relationships.
And the mathematics that's
important is game theory.
And game theory is this idea
that when people interact,
it's as if they were selecting
from a set of strategies
in order to maximize some metric
that has to do with pay off
or utility.
So it's like, Julie and I are
interacting, and each of us
are selecting what we're
going to do with one another
for some purpose.
And, turns out that when
you solve various games
and find a solution, that there
are two possible solutions
that you come up with.
One is called the
Von Neumann solution.
and the Von Neumann
solution is basically
selecting the best of the worst.
So, you think about
the relationship
and you go, well let
me cut my losses.
I don't want to expect much
from this relationship, so let
me figure out how
not to get hurt.
You interact that way.
That's one way of
solving any game.
Another way is called
the Nash solution,
and John Nash won the Nobel
Prize for this solution.
And here, what
you're trying to do
is get to the best
for both people.
And so, the metric
you're trying to maximize
is not only your own
benefit, but your partner's
benefit as well.
So trust is really
having a metric
where you care as much
about how your partner does,
as you do about
how you're doing.
Where you care about
your partner's feelings,
your partner's needs, as much
as you care about your own.
And that's how you build
trust, is really the idea of,
I have my partner's back.
Which is, I know that when
Julie and I are negotiating
some decision we're
trying to make,
and I have one point of view and
she has another point of view.
That she's thinking
not only of herself,
she's thinking also about
me, and how I'm going to fare
and what's good for me, and
I'm thinking about that as well
for her.
We're going to arrive at the
Nash equilibrium, the Nash
solution.
Well, how do you arrive at that?
And what our research tells us,
is that the way to build trust
is to be there as
a great listener
when your partner is upset.
That negative emotions are the
magic moments for connecting.
So, not what you
would you think.
It's just really that
couples who build trust
appear to have a motto
in which they're saying,
baby when you are in pain,
the world stops and I listen.
I care.
I care about what you feel,
I care about what you nee,d
and that's what builds trust.
JULIE GOTTMAN: And let me
add a little bit to that,
and then talk about
how we recover
when there's been betrayal.
So part of being trustworthy
is when your partner turns
towards you, for anything,
just a bid for attention,
or a need of some sort,
they're really tired,
they want you to do a little
extra housework or something.
When do you do?
Do you turn towards
them and say, sure.
Yeah, I'll take care
of that for you,
or do you simply ignore them.
If they are call
your name and you're
right in the middle
of reading something,
or you're doing your
e-mail what do you?
Do you stop your
email and say, yeah.
Or, do you keep
doing your email?
Or do you say, stop interrupting
me, I'm finishing my work,
which is turning against, right?
So, there's a huge
difference in building trust
in terms of turning towards,
versus turning away,
where we don't respond at
all, versus turning against.
So, the more you can turn
towards your partner,
the deeper the friendship
is, the more your partner
trusts you to be there for them.
And the more your
partner may also
be willing to give back to you.
So, it deepens the trust
system between the two of you,
which is wonderful.
OK, so let's talk about betrayal
and what leads up to betrayal.
The heart of what
leads up to betrayal,
which we've seen in our work,
is people avoid conflict,
isn't that interesting?
So, John was saying something
wonderful a moment ago,
which is, negative
moments are magic.
They are opening a door
to greater intimacy,
because if you process,
if you actually
talk about those
negative emotions
you may be having, even
about your partner, or about
something else, your
partner is learning what's
important to you.
Your partner is learning
what you really need,
what you really feel.
They may be learning more
about baggage from your past
that you brought into
this relationship.
It's all important.
So, you don't avoid conflict
if you want to build trust.
If you do, what starts happening
is the resentment builds up,
right?
You're unhappy about stuff.
You are not talking about
it, you get more, and more,
and more unhappy.
And the more the
resentment builds,
the more distance
grows between you,
and then eventually you
grow quite lonely, right?
Because you've been looking
to your partner for a deeper
connection, and it ain't there.
So, what happens?
You start comparing your partner
to somebody else, somebody
at work who you just had
this lovely conversation
with at the popcorn bin.
You guys have popcorn, right?
And that's a lovely
conversation.
And you think, God that person
was so warm and so friendly
and so outgoing, and you start
comparing the partner at home
to this one.
And it's those
negative comparisons,
my partner wouldn't
do that, my partner
wouldn't smile at me like that.
The negative comparisons
then lead you
towards confiding
in that person,
and then eventually
talking to that person
about your
relationship, et cetera.
And they're going aw,
poor dear, poor dear,
and being sympathetic.
And before you know
it, there's bonding
and eventual infidelity.
So, that's one common path.
How do you recover?
Well, first of all,
you don't lie about it
in the first place.
It's got to be open.
If a person is deceiving and
lying about having an affair,
it's a double betrayal.
One, going outside of monogamy,
if that's your agreement,
and two, lying about it.
So, what needs to
happen in terms
of the recovery-- and we're
going to be doing a research
project on this,
and typically this
needs to happen in therapy, it's
very hard to do without some.
First, the person
whose been betrayed
needs to be able to
ask all the questions
they have about the
affair, and the betrayer
needs to be able to
answer those questions.
But, what's also
important is that person
whose being betrayed
typically suffers
from post-traumatic
stress disorder.
You guys have all heard
about that, right?
In relation to combat vets
or maybe abuse histories.
Same thing happens
with an affair,
that's what you're
causing your partner.
So they become hyper-vigilant.
They are constantly suspecting
an [INAUDIBLE], another affair.
They are waking up at
night with nightmares.
They're having intrusive
images in their mind,
of you with the person, which
they don't want to have,
but they're having
anyway, and their emotions
are spiking all over the place,
they're having big explosions.
That's all PTSD.
So that needs to be explained.
And then, the person who's
done the betraying really
needs to be able to here the
feelings of the person who
has been betrayed.
So, the betrayer needs to hear
the feelings of the betrayed.
Really hear them.
But, here's where
therapy comes in.
Therapy needs to
somewhat coach the person
who's been betrayed, to not
use contempt and criticism
to express the anger and pain.
As that process slowly
winds down, which it does,
then you look at rebuilding
marriage number two.
Because an affair
destroys marriage.
But you can still build
marriage number two,
by opening up how to do conflict
in a much better way, how
to turn toward the
other person, how
to express honest admiration.
And over time the
relationship is rebuilt,
and oftentimes it's
stronger than ever.
So people definitely
do recover from affairs
if they get some help
LOGAN URY: Thank you.
So, I want to shift
gears a little bit.
You two are the
experts on marriage,
and this has been a bit
year for gay marriage.
And in all the
research that I study
on the relationships and
marriage, so much of it
is focused on
heterosexual couples.
I know you've done some work
in the lesbian community.
Can you talk a bit
about any differences
that you see with gender
roles or any other changes
in a gay relationship?
JOHN GOTTMAN: My colleague
Bob Levenson and I
studied committed gay
and lesbian couples
for a dozen years, and we
found the same principles apply
to gay and lesbian
committed relationships
as to heterosexual
married couples.
There were some
differences qualitatively.
One really
interesting difference
was that most heterosexual
couples in the subcultures
in the United States,
except for Latino
and Hispanic subcultures,
are very embarrassed
talking about sex, even when
there's no camera there,
with one another.
And are very indirect
in what they asked for.
They don't have a way of
initiating sex, a formal way
of talking about it.
And so gay and
lesbian couples are
very different than
heterosexual couples that way.
They're little very open
and very direct in talking
about what they need sexually.
But the overriding
the difference
was that gay and lesbian couples
were a lot nicer to each other
than heterosexual couples.
They were gentler in the way
they presented their conflicts,
and they were less
defensive, and there
was more of a sense of humor.
And we know that there's
a lot more sensitivity
in gay and lesbian couples
to power differentials
in the relationship
and a desire--
maybe because there is
less choice, only 10%
of the population
is gay or lesbian.
Because there's less
choice, I think,
they're more willing to
have an equal relationship,
even if there are differences
in income or education,
to really make sure that there's
not that power differential.
LOGAN URY: Do you
predict anything
will change as it goes
from committed long-term
relationships to
official marriage?
JOHN GOTTMAN: Yes, I really do.
I think the difference
is that they will feel,
gay and lesbian couples will
feel more a part of society,
rather than defensive
about who they are.
They'll really be
accepted, they'll
be really are treated as equals.
JULIE GOTTMAN: Yeah, let me
add to that a little bit.
Less positive note.
But first, I did the
first study in the country
on when daughters were
raised by lesbian mothers,
how did they turn out compared
to the daughters of hetero
moms.
And this was back in 1980.
When kids were in
custody situations
with the hetero parent,
when the mom wanted to go
live a lesbian lifestyle.
And the kids were
being taken away
from the mother, every single
time, because she was lesbian.
And they would often be given
to a heroin-addicted father,
an alcoholic grandfather.
They'd be given to anybody else,
but taken away from the mother.
So the study that I
was fortunate to do,
and very supported
by many lesbian
moms and their daughters,
showed that, of course,
the daughters, who
are now adults,
were actually doing better,
having been raised by lesbian
moms, in terms of
social adjustment,
and there were no differences
in gender-identity and sexual
orientation.
It was exactly the same.
So now, the thing that
I'm beginning to hear,
which really me
frightens me, which
you guys might want
to be aware of,
is that as gay marriage
has now become the law,
there are groups in America
who are trying to roll back
the laws about gay adoption.
Because the research
that I and many others
did at that time, allowed
gay parents, lesbian parents,
or gay and lesbian
couples to adopt kids.
Well, now they're
trying to roll it back.
So, there's still tension
this issue despite the fact
that, hooray, gay and
lesbians can now marry.
LOGAN URY: That's
really interesting.
JULIE GOTTMAN: And
subsequent research
to Julie's landmark study,
has replicated that effect
and show that gay
and lesbian couples
are every bit as good parents.
And in fact, my
personal experience,
sort of trailing along as a
spouse when Julie give talks
for concerned gay
and lesbian parents,
was that they were
much more concerned
than heterosexual parents that
will then be terrible parents,
and they really go for
parental education classes
and workshops.
So, I think just
the opposite is true
and I think it's worthwhile
raising this alarm.
LOGAN URY: The
kids are all right.
JOHN GOTTMAN: Yes, they are.
JULIE GOTTMAN: Kids are great.
LOGAN URY: So, I've been
wondering this for a long time.
You're famous for your ability
to predict a couple's success
rate for staying together in
a next three to five years
with more than 90% accuracy.
So, as you're doing
research, and you
see a couple that's really,
the four horseman are present,
there's all these issues.
Do you say anything to them?
Do you say better watch
out or don't get married?
JULIE GOTTMAN: (SINGING)
You better not cry.
It's the season.
LOGAN URY: And then
I was wondering,
are you ever at a coffee
shop or on an airplane
and you hear a couple,
do you ever go up to them
and say, listen-- [LAUGHTER]
JULIE GOTTMAN: Wait,
I get to talk first.
[LAUGHTER] See that's how--
he accepts influence, that's
another really important
thing, in terms
of successful relationships.
JOHN GOTTMAN: That's
enlightened self-interest.
[LAUGHTER]
JULIE GOTTMAN: First of
all, no we don't do that.
Otherwise, we'd never get
invited to dinner. [LAUGHTER].
[INAUDIBLE] out in the public--
our invitations drop down
[INAUDIBLE].
So, you don't typically
do that, because these
are group statistics.
They're all group
statistics, so there's always
exceptions in group statistics.
On the other hand,
I have to tell you
a story, which is we have
one child, one daughter,
we were really old when
we had her, so any of you
who have old parents, know
that your parents will dote all
over you, and hover
and protect you,
So when our daughter was
two, John put her in front
of the t.v. with videos
from the lab, and said
what you think about how
that father, what do you
think about those two?
Are they doing okay or not?
And we've been doing that with
her, poor thing, [LAUGHTER]
we not only set up the college
fund but a psychotherapy fund.
[LAUGHTER] She's the daughter
of two psychologists, so.
Yeah, we rarely tell people
they should split up,
but every now and
then we do, when
there's definite abuse and
no clear path for change.
JOHN GOTTMAN: Sometimes,
it's really painful,
like we did this study of
couples having first baby,
and we followed them
from a couple of months
after the wedding, and
we found that 2/3 of them
had a big drop in
relationship happiness
in the first three years
of the baby's life.
You know, 2/3 of them.
And when Julie and I
designed this workshop,
two day workshop called
"Bringing Baby Home,"
we could reverse that
trend for almost 80%
of the couples in just two days.
We could do that.
And we were at a
restaurant recently,
and I saw this young couple
and they had a new baby,
and they all also had
about a five-year-old girl,
and they weren't
speaking to each other
throughout the whole
dinner, and the glances
were pretty negative.
And I was just dying
to go over to them
and say, would you
take our workshop,
[LAUGHTER] because
you can avoid all
of this pain in such a short
time, and prevent this misery.
But I don't feel I can do
that, go over to somebody
and say that.
But I would really--
LOGAN URY: It's like you have
a superpower-- [LAUGHTER]
JOHN GOTTMAN: Yeah, right.
LOGAN URY: So I have
so many more questions
I'm going to just ask one,
so that we can open it
up to the audience afterward,
but in my own personal
research, in talking to people
about their relationships,
the question I get the
most is, how do I know
if I'm with the right person?
And when do I settle down?
And are my standards too high?
And through you, I discovered
to research of Don Baucom
about realistic versus
idealistic standards.
I was wondering if you can
talk about this, especially
for people in the audience or
on YouTube who are thinking,
am I'm with the right person?
Or, how do I find
the right person?
JOHN GOTTMAN: You
know, every couple
of months when I used to
watch "Oprah Winfrey," there'd
be this depressed
psychiatrist on,
as an expert on relationships,
I think his advice was always,
lower your
expectations, you know.
And he said, don't expect
anything from people,
because it's really going to
be bad if you expect something,
you'll always be disappointed.
This guy looked so depressed.
But you hear this advice
over and over again,
don't expect anything, because
high expectations are the death
knell of relationship.
So Don Baucom, at the
University of North Carolina,
spent a decade studying this,
and he found just the opposite.
That when people expect
to be treated well,
that's what they get
in relationships.
And when people have
lowered their expectations,
so that they're OK
being treated like dirt,
that's what they get.
So his advice was
have high expectations
and expect to be treated well,
and bail out a relationship
if you're getting treated badly.
JULIE GOTTMAN: One of
the things that I really
love to tell folks is,
how does your partner make
you feel about yourself?
So if, when you're with that
partner, you feel handsome,
you feel beautiful, you feel
smart, and you feel cherished.
You feel like your
partner really
respects you, that's a sign that
the relationship is a good one.
If, on the other hand, you feel
insecure, you feel nervous,
you feel scared.
You feel like, God was that
a stupid thing I just said?
How come they're not responding?
Why are they always
looking away?
Why are they looking
at the other people
instead of looking at me?
Those kinds of questions
indicate to you
a big question mark in terms
of whether the relationship is
really working for you.
JOHN GOTTMAN: Yeah.
Let me tell a story.
I was talking to somebody
in a shop, this shopkeeper,
and she said I'm now really
in a good relationship,
but I used to be in
this relationship
where the guy always
said to me, why
do you have to laugh so much?
And why do you have
to laugh so loud?
Can't you think
before you laugh?
[LAUGHTER] That was
his message to me.
And she said, when I
was thinking about it,
nobody thinks before they
laugh, they just laugh
or they don't laugh, right?
And I'm now with somebody who
just loves the way I laugh,
and I'm with this guy
and he's just perfect.
LOGAN URY: That's
a beautiful story,
and I'm also really
happy about what
you said about keeping
high standards,
because I think this
community, especially,
is one where people are
going to hold off until they
find the right person.
And I think it's
a great reminder
that you shouldn't
lower your standards,
even if your family and
friends are telling you to.
[LAUGHTER]
JULIE GOTTMAN: Spoken
like a strong young woman.
[LAUGHTER]
LOGAN URY: We'll see how
my boyfriend and I do
at your workshop. [LAUGHTER]
JULIE GOTTMAN: We'll
be watching, you know.
LOGAN URY: So I
want to make sure
that people in the audience
have a chance ask questions.
There's a mic right
here, so please
feel free to come up to the
podium and ask a question.
Don't be shy.
If you're able to make your way
up or I'll pass the microphone
back.
AUDIENCE: I could yell, too.
JULIE GOTTMAN:
We've got one here.
Or not.
LOGAN URY: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I'm actually a
counselor in Washington,
I see couples and individuals,
adult individuals.
And one of the things that I've
shifted in my practice now,
is that I'm seeing more arranged
marriages in my practice,
and it feels like it's a whole
different ball of wax, doing
counseling with them.
And I'm wondering, have
you done any research
on arranged marriages versus
one where, here in the US,
we get to select?
JOHN GOTTMAN: But we
haven't systematically
studied arranged marriages, but
there is quite a big research
literature on this,
and I just want
to say that the same
principles apply.
That respect and
affection is what
makes those relationships work.
Now, arranged marriages
are very different when
they're in the community that
has arranged the marriages,
because then there is a
lot of social support,
and sociologists have found
that it's not religiosity
or any of that, that
determines the greater
stability of arranged
marriages, but that
continued social support.
So, if a couple has an
arranged marriage in Calcutta,
then they moved to Seattle,
a very different kind
of situation.
And they're at some
peril, because they
don't have that community of
support that intervenes when
he loses his job,
or they're running
through some difficult times.
JULIE GOTTMAN: On
the other hand,
one has to be pretty careful in
terms-- I've done a lot of work
with arranged marriages as
well, and one of the things
to look out for, in terms
of that community support--
is because the marriage
has been arranged,
the people who arranged it
have great investment in it
continuing.
And in the event that there is
some domestic violence, which
I've seen a lot of, they do
not want to support, typically,
the wife to leave.
And they want her
to stay, and they
tell her to put up with it, it's
been put up for generations,
oh well.
It's OK, be a good wife.
And that is a problem.
JOHN GOTTMAN: Yep.
JULIE GOTTMAN: Big problem.
AUDIENCE: Hi so-- [LAUGHTER]
so I read several of your books
and I really enjoyed them.
But I notice a lot
of your research
is focused on long term couples.
For people who are single,
or just starting to date,
do you have any books that you
recommend or that you wrote?
JULIE GOTTMAN: So,
part of the problem
is that there has been
this much research
on dating and single
people, and how
to make a good relationship.
So all of the
internet stuff, I mean
there is no research
that backs it up.
And so we need to
do that research,
we would love to
we have talked about
doing that research,
we don't have the money
to do that research.
But, it's a very valid thing to
be looking at because people,
especially if they're coming
out of divorced homes,
and many are, don't know
what to look for in terms
of a decent relationship.
So, good question.
JOHN GOTTMAN: You know,
one of the things that's
so interesting about research on
relationships at the beginning,
selecting somebody, is that
the research is just awful.
And part of the problem is
that these matching services
are using the wrong algorithm.
They're trying to help
people find their clone,
and find somebody
just like you, has
the same interest,
the same philosophy
of life, the same personality.
And for what we know
about, how pheromones
work in initial
selection-- people
select t-shirts that's
smell good, based
upon the pheromones there.
They're selecting their
genetically more diverse
person.
On the major
histocompatibility complex
they're selecting people
who are different from them,
very different.
So, we've got the
wrong algorithm there,
and that's just an
indicator that we really
don't know how to help
select the right mate.
But I think that the guide is to
find somebody who really likes
the way you laugh,
thinks you're funny,
and really enjoys your company
and you enjoy their company
and that's really the best
guide we have at the moment.
LOGAN URY: I'd love to
hear this guy's question.
[LAUGHTER] It better
be really great.
No pressure.
AUDIENCE: One thing I find
interesting about your work
is that it's based on data.
Like it was quoted earlier
that during the stonewalling,
the beat rate went
up 100, 140, and that
made me really curious,
is that conducted
in a laboratory setting?
Are couples then put
in a Tetris situation,
in a lab and then studied?
JOHN GOTTMAN: We've studied
them in several ways.
One is a standard
kind of situations
that are designed
to elicit conflict,
or having them talk
about how their day went
after they've been apart
for at least eight hours.
But in the love lab I built
at University of Washington,
couples just hang
out for 24 hours
and the videotape
is just rolling,
no instructions at all.
So we watch them
having dinner, we
watch them reading
the newspaper,
cleaning up after
dinner, stuff like that.
So, there you can just
look at everyday moments,
and they're wearing
Holter monitors,
so we're looking at their
heart rate, electrocardiogram,
and when they urinate,
we take a urine sample.
That measures stress hormones.
We take blood from that too.
But-- [LAUGHTER]
LOGAN URY: There's no
cameras in the bathroom.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, my
name's Craig, I'm here
with my wife of more than 28
years, we've been married.
JULIE GOTTMAN: Yay!
AUDIENCE: But you mentioned
at the very start, the four
horsemen.
And I can think of many
times in our relationship
when all four have been
present, stampeding
through the room, causing hate
and destruction and everything.
Yet, we've still
managed to continue on.
And I was wondering, if the
presence of the four horsemen
is always there, and you're
just trying to keep them at bay,
or is it trying to
not ever live them
exist in your relationship?
I guess I'm a little
confused there,
because we should've broken
up many, many years ago,
because of the horseman's
presence for so many times?
But at the same time, we seem to
have survived past that and yet
they're still there, so--
JULIE GOTTMAN: Right oh.
Right.
I mean, they are
for us too, right?
So, you know we're
all human beings.
And as human beings, we
do have moments where
we are not editing ourselves.
Have you guys ever
heard of Cokie Roberts?
You know who she is?
She's at NPR, fabulous
political commentator.
And she and her husband, who
is a senator from Tennessee,
wrote a book about
their marriage.
And one of the things that
they said, that was wonderful,
is a sign of a good
marriage is how many teeth
marks you have in your tongue.
[LAUGHTER] So, what we saw
in our research though,
is that, just by having high
expectations for your marriage,
there is also our
concept of what
is that good enough marriage.
Good enough, right?
So that doesn't mean perfect.
Nobody really gets
away in their marriage
without having the incidents of
being critical, or defensive,
or even contemptuous, whatever.
We all will slide into
that from time to time.
This is a very critical
culture we've grown up in,
so we come by it righteously.
We know where criticism
looks like, most of us.
And so it comes trippingly
to the tongue when
we're angry about something.
So, what we saw though,
is that the couples who
were successful, had a
little bit less of it,
but they still did
it from time to time.
But they made repairs.
They made repairs.
After they were critical,
after they were contemptuous,
after they were too
defensive or stonewalling,
they would go back and
say, you know what?
I really hated how I just put
you down half an hour ago.
I want to apologize
for that, and they
might have a conversation
about, what was going on
with you when that happened?
And what we've seen
in our clinical work,
it's one of the tools that we
give in our couple's workshops,
that you too will get to learn,
is that when couples can go
back and process a
regrettable incident,
a bad fight they've had, as if
they were sitting in the upper
balcony of the theatre
looking down on the stage.
And saying, what the heck
happened during Act One?
And understand, from your
partners point of view,
what their partner
was feeling, what
their partner was receiving,
and do that in both directions.
Really listening to
the other person.
And then owning responsibility
for whatever they contributed
to that regrettable incident.
It's a beautiful way
of, again, taking
something regrettable
that's happened
and turning it into magic.
Turning it into understanding
the other person's
inner-life in a much deeper way.
LOGAN URY: I think we have time
for one more quick question.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so
much for coming here.
For those of us who
have young children
but aren't able to attend
your two day workshops,
what are some of
the things that are
specific to couples
with young children,
both in terms of the problems
that they experience,
and also in terms of
strategies that they can use?
JOHN GOTTMAN: Sure, one of the
things that is very important
is that, when you
become a parent,
you've made a huge
philosophical leap.
I'm sure you experienced this
when you became a father.
That you become infinitely
vulnerable, right?
I mean, no question
that you'd stop a mac
truck to save your kids' life.
Automatically, you know that
if something bad happened
to your kid, it'd be disastrous.
And you've immediately
joined the family
of man, the family
of mankind, humanity.
And you become so
vulnerable, and you're
able to love at a level that
is beyond what you imagined.
So, it's a huge change, and
loving this creature together
with your wife,
with your partner,
is a very powerful bond.
And a part of what we
teach in this workshop
is how to listen to babies.
How to understand babies operate
on a completely different time
scale from us, much slower.
And if you can slow down
and be you with your baby,
and enjoy the fact that there
was no toy on the planet
that is as interesting to
your baby as your face,
and there's no music as
interesting as your voice
to that baby.
And it's a hell of a lot of
fun to be with that child,
and spend time with that child.
And I'll tell you one really
quick story, which is-- OK,
and then you get to talk.
[LAUGHTER] We were talking
to a [INAUDIBLE] reservation
one time, and we're talking
about the importance
of listening to children,
and they were saying well
people have been
telling us, speakers
have been telling us to
tell stories to children.
Stories about our culture
and our people, and you're
telling us to listen.
And I ask people,
how many of you
remember what it was
like to be a kid?
And some hands went up.
And I said, of those
of you who remember
what it was like to be
a child, how many of you
had an adult who treated you
with respect and kindness
and listened to you?
And only a few hands
stayed up, and I
said would you be willing
to share your stories?
And all those people
talked and wept
as they talked about the fact
that my grandmother, when
I walked into her room, she
would brighten and sit down,
drop what she was
doing and listen to me,
and celebrated me and found me
interesting, and respected me.
So I think that's really
what I would recommend
as the key thing, is to learn
how to listen to your child.
JULIE GOTTMAN: OK.
So let me ask you
something, are you sleep
deprived or is your partner?
AUDIENCE: Yes, and yes.
[LAUGHTER]
JULIE GOTTMAN: OK then,
let me just mention
to you that sleep deprivation
is a biggie for young parents,
and after 30 days, typically,
of interrupted night's sleep,
people will-- almost everyone
will show many, many signs
of clinical depression.
What that means is
that young parents tend
to be more irritable with one
another, a little bit more
withdrawn, more exhausted,
conflict goes up.
Aren't you glad
you had children?
[LAUGHTER] You know,
wonderful moments too,
but the work has tripled, and
you're exhausted all the time.
So, part of what
we really recommend
is not only listening
to your kids,
but listening to each other.
So having, if you can
have what we call a little
ritual of connection.
Which means, a time of
connecting with your partner
that you can really count
on, that's predictable.
If you can have a stress
reducing conversation
in the evenings, even
when you're exhausted,
of how was your day, dear?
Tell me about your day.
And each of you can
whine and complain
to each other, that is really
useful, where people are just
empathizing with one
another to stay connected.
Because when you're
so busy, parents
find they don't have much time
to just talk to each other,
hang out with each other.
So it's really important to
build in rituals of connection
to do that.
That are talking about things
other than, did you call
the plumber.
So, that's one.
Another is, if at all
possible, have a date night.
Have a date night, where
you go out once a week.
Even when the kids are
little you can do that.
And, that third, if
you can possibly,
it depends on how old your
kids are, once in a while,
have an overnight.
You know, just, all you'll
do to is talk about you kids.
Know that, but you
won't be interrupted
while you're doing that.
Which is a good thing.
And, they can get
our book. [LAUGHTER]
JOHN GOTTMAN: [INAUDIBLE].
JULIE GOTTMAN: So, our book
has all of this, but anyway.
So, staying connected with your
partner is super important,
and building in those
rituals of connection, where
you can really count on talking
to each other is wonderful,
helps the marriage.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
LOGAN URY: Well, that's all.
That's it for time,
but thank you so much,
this was really a dream
of mine [INAUDIBLE].
[APPLAUSE]